at the most basic level the news you
consume is a lie you are being
manipulated how does that work let's see
if I tell you that a man has been
unjustly arrested for armed robbery that
is not strictly speaking a lie he may
have been framed at this point there's
been no trial so no one can really say
but if I don't mention the fact that the
same man has been arrested for the same
crime six times before am I really
informing you no I'm not I'm misleading
you and that's what the news media are
doing in every story that matters every
day of the week every week of the year
the best you can hope for in the news
business at this point is the freedom to
tell the fullest truth that you can but
there are always limits and you know
that if you bump up against those limits
often enough you will be fired for it
the importance of this situation can't
be overestimated Tucker and the amount
of influence he has no longer on Fox
News and I think this is really going to
strengthen say the the pond that I'm in
the